yeah no it's fine yes hello and welcome
to this video please playing Walter
without fighter from Argentina let's see
for Reggie system no here actually
checking getting the porn back quickly
keep on screwing of new orders him I
definitely know that I do I think this
voluntary retreat is correct then a form
the temperature ly a five if I can get
the Zen this is what I'd like to achieve
to get this a 5 binding and I think this
should be over all right if I go 85 now
we might play Bishop 37 not the end of
the world though I can start with this
maybe and now let's go away five please
Bishop c7 and Michael Bishop d to cover
it like that if he goes b6 in this
position or in the near future here we
go b5 is just the same we will get a
position where might be porn is somewhat
weak but he's called a week see and a
porn so good this should be slightly
very slightly better for wide aha so I
cannot take 35 him to take a three-play
97 okay then loses an exchange I wonder
if this is a good move here
hmm still as the discoveries ok northern
bishop defense okay hmm ha where am I
going with this I would like to move the
Queen away but where exactly i also have
Bishop g5 yeah this is actually move
that I like potentially just trading and
allowing that BTW to that's a smooth
development okay yeah that makes sense
also threaten to take on f3 okay I'm
taking and I takes with the Queen uh-huh
[Music]
didn't expect that to happen and
threatening to take take on b2 okay okay
when I can go now 233 also please ideal
would be 92 Nazi for me if I can get the
light squared Bishop traded and then I
to see for myself my position is really
good it might happen that the a porn
would be to be substantially week not
easy to play this year with black okay
when I see somewhat stuck with this with
this inferior structure not much fun
Miami has to trade basically there's no
avoiding the trade this is the matter
how exactly is going to do it Yahoo
basics is just hanging if you have to
play group I ate something is seriously
wrong maybe you have 20 min then the
next night is on the way to c4 and then
I have the the ideal setup the the dummy
Bishop here against the super light I
could I couldn't eat yet but that will
be possible soonish i believe i gotta go
to page and queen a formed so great a
shirt a Google form now okay about it
it's good anyway
now I didn't play it perfectly
absolutely not hmm how to do this should
put this on a three
yeah black will never get rid of the
structural problem is the pro is the
thing so we are taking now it's a bit
too lame to going for there should be
five over to see up to maybe just trade
one here I love it
[Music]
yeah bring the Queen around to see two
and now my group 1 a 2 and then taking
it could be the right way to do it
yeah maybe night a5 is threatened now it
so he covered it like that still not let
Keeley Arabic and win it okay that
didn't work maybe I just have to trade
one who can it's absolutely possible but
if i move the night time going to try
that for 93 I wonder about the should be
five in this position and that doesn't
work okay now he here sometime issue him
III or not
as threatening on g3 a.m.
kim extremely tough to do something here
of course it looks bad somehow for black
but doing something real is a different
matter 18 seconds though I'm still what
like okay I'm happy with that hi Joe
they were difficult Lu White was
obviously better but doing something
with it wasn't wasn't all that easy I
would have liked to trade it one look
this is kind of a perfect situation up
like a sitting there with with
weaknesses but so tough yet it was a
result of the opening where I got this
this a five bind in this kind of
situation always should be a little
something for why it's tough to not play
the B pawn in the long run and here this
is exactly I think correct the engines
evaluation something like half a pond or
something is why does why this is better
here in some way so this one and now I'm
getting close to this the situation may
get the night against the bishop so this
is really nice but maybe an
and I'm not playing it right and it's
it's absolutely possible i think i lost
some time you also this is for example
just a time loss so the Queen has to go
back now so what's there a moment where
I could take their the engine gives an
advantage for black is this is quite
ridiculous actually black is that can
never be better and I'm in this position
simply because I mean if I just want to
want to stay and do nothing I just move
around it's basically a fortress if I
want but I can always try stuff so why
would this be better Bishop f6 here I
because it's a temple ok now that it
could be F so I have to go back yeah
it's actually true that's true so then I
then I played something wrong here the
gooks III was wrong I can actually take
on 85 ok I didn't see that was thinking
as always this but 96 is possible it is
all with the temple after that ok and
the dep dep sorry when Bishop F
successor is different and here doesn't
also find all that much yeah yeah what
we're thinking as it must be nice for
white but how do you actually do
something it seems that black is just an
active enough I didn't see anything and
it seems if the engine doesn't find
anything it's probably just not as great
as it looks yet here we would little bit
with the with no time
something will turn up man I ok 5 yeah
okay I've got 10 seconds on the clock
that's interesting him I really thought
that this this kind of position should
be so advantageous but it's probably
really not that clear I noticed that the
computer he wanted to play ok for yeah
maybe this is better and just going for
the palm up like the c5 point not
locating it but attacking it maybe
that's better ok thanks for watching